Programming Throwdown Episode 147 Quantum Computing with Yonatan Cohen. Take it away, Patrick. Hey, everyone. Welcome to another episode. Today, I'm excited to be able to have someone to talk to about quantum computing. This is something even dating back many years that I've been intrigued about. I've read various superficial descriptions of, but never really been able to go in depth about with quantum computing and I'm excited that we're here today with Yonatan Kohin, co-founder and CTO of Quantum Machines. Welcome to Programming Throwdown. Hi, it's great to be here. Thank you for inviting me. Awesome. Well, we normally get started by a little bit of an introduction about yourself, how you got into technology. Some people have like that one
编程泛论第147期：量子计算，嘉宾乔纳森·科恩。交给你了，帕特里克。大家好，欢迎收看又一期节目。今天，我很高兴能请到一位嘉宾来聊聊量子计算。这甚至可以追溯到多年前，我一直对它很感兴趣。我读过各种浮光掠影的描述，但从未真正能够深入探讨量子计算，我很高兴我们今天请到了量子机器（Quantum Machines）的联合创始人兼首席托（CTO）乔纳森·科恩。欢迎来到编程泛论。嗨，很高兴来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。太棒了。好吧，我们通常从简短的自我介绍开始，关于你自己，你是如何进入科技领域的。有些人有那种一次性的
time they remember that, you know, maybe their parents brought home a computer or they went to school and the Oregon Trail was put in on a floppy disk. Do you sort of remember your first like exposure to computers or technology? To computers in general? Yes. So yeah, I did. I did get a computer at a very early stage. And I was also very interested in physics, in fundamental physics, since I was very young. But really, I got into quantum computing when I was at university. So I did my bachelor's degree at the University of Washington in Seattle. And I had a great teacher. So it's all about teachers, you know.
他们记得的经历，你知道的，也许他们的父母带回了一台电脑，或者他们去上学，在一张软盘上加载了俄勒冈之旅（The Oregon Trail）。你还记得你第一次接触电脑或科技的经历吗？对电脑的总体印象？是的。所以，是的，我确实如此。我确实很早就得到了一台电脑。而且我从小就对物理学，对基础物理学非常感兴趣。但我真正接触量子计算是在上大学的时候。我在西雅图的华盛顿大学读了我的学士学位。我遇到了一位好老师。所以，你知道的，一切都在于老师。
So a professor at at University of Washington. His name is Boris Blinov. And he was this great guy and he was teaching quantum mechanics 101. And that kind of blew my mind because it kind of connects computing and fundamental physics, which are two topics that I truly loved from a very early age.
所以华盛顿大学的一位教授。他的名字叫鲍里斯·布利诺夫。他是个很棒的家伙，当时他在教量子力学入门。这让我大开眼界，因为它把计算和基础物理学联系在了一起，这两个主题我从小就非常热爱。
And that kind of like from a very early age. And that kind of like brought things together for me. And since then, I'm hooked on this subject. Oh, nice. You know, it's interesting. There's actually like a lot of people we talk to who kind of have this physics, computer science, like hybrid, you know, kind of crossover, I guess, like the ways of thinking maybe are same. I mean, there's the obvious, like computers use physics to work, but like, I mean, I feel like still,
这有点像——从小时候起。这让我把这些东西联系在了一起。从那以后，我就迷上了这个课题。哦，太好了。你知道，这很有趣。实际上，我们交谈过的很多人都有这种物理学和计算机科学的混合交叉背景，你知道的，也许思考方式是一样的。我的意思是，显而易见的一点是，计算机利用物理学来工作，但是，我的意思是，我觉得仍然，
there's a lot of, a lot of crossover there. That's like a pretty common background. Right. I mean, it's, it's interesting because, yeah, I mean, the reason I went to physics and not to computer. So when I was, when I was very young, I was obsessed with, so how does a computer work? You know, like when you're a kid, you know, why do I see those things on the screen? Yeah, like how does it all works? And then I took a few courses and at some point,
有很多，有很多重叠的地方。这算是一个相当普遍的背景。对吧。我的意思是，这很有趣，因为，是的，我的意思是，我选择物理学而不是计算机的原因。当我小的时候，我很痴迷于，计算机是如何工作的？你知道的，就像你是个孩子时，为什么我能在屏幕上看到那些东西？是的，比如这一切是如何运作的？然后我上了几门课，在某个时候，
and I was obsessed also with how the universe works, you know, like why do I see all these things around me? You know, so it's kind of like the same thing, just replace, you know, everything that you see around you and the screen of the computer. So apparently, i think it's easier to understand how computers work than than how the universe works um so i feel we're gonna go deep right out the beginning yeah so sometimes during high school i realized okay yeah i think i understand how a computer
我也很痴迷于宇宙是如何运作的，你知道的，为什么我能看到身边的所有这些东西？所以这有点像同一件事，只是把，你知道的，你周围看到的一切和计算机的屏幕替换掉了。所以显然，我认为理解计算机的工作原理比理解宇宙的工作原理要容易，嗯，所以我觉得我们一开始就要深入探讨了。是的，所以高中时期的某个时候我意识到，好吧，是的，我大概理解了计算机是
works so i better just go in the physics direction. But once I learned about quantum computing, I think it's interesting because I think that quantum computing is really, so some of it is about, you know, what's possible to compute, you know, is to compute, you know, with certain amount of time, certain amount of resources. And that sort of goes back into the kind of fundamental how the universe works thing you know uh for me oh man are we gonna ask that question are we all in a simulation is it are we headed to the end so we're just gonna tee it up right at the beginning for sure um yeah i mean no i mean i don't know if it's simulation but you you could view you know the laws of physics is kind of like uh you know some kind of a very sophisticated program and you can ask what, the laws of physics is kind of like, you know, some kind of a very sophisticated
如何工作的，所以我最好还是朝物理学方向发展。但一旦我了解了量子计算，我认为这很有趣，因为我认为量子计算确实，其中一部分关乎，你知道的，什么是可计算的，你知道的，是用一定的时间，一定量的资源来进行计算。这有点回到了那种关于宇宙如何运作的基础物理学问题，你知道的，对我来说。哦，天哪，我们要问那个问题吗？我们都在模拟中吗？难道我们正走向终点吗？所以我们一开始就要把话题挑明了。肯定的，嗯，是的，我的意思是，不，我的意思是，我不知道这是不是模拟，但你可以把物理定律看作是某种，你知道的，某种非常复杂的程序，你可以问，物理定律有点像，你知道的，某种非常复杂的
program. And you can ask, what are the rules of programming? And these are the rules of physics, right? And quantum computing builds on that. And another interesting thing is that there are a lot of interesting thinkings right now, which might be the first applications of quantum computers as to how quantum computers can allow us also to understand deep concepts in physics. So now it's going back, the direction goes back, and maybe these computers can help us understand fundamental physics better. Wow. Oh, that's cool. Yeah. It's interesting sometimes how those things go in cycles and iterations and sort of one helps the other, the other helps back, and it's kind of fun that the other, the other helps back. And it's sort of,
程序。你可以问，编程的规则是什么？这些就是物理学的规则，对吧？量子计算就是建立在此基础上的。另一个有趣的事情是，现在有很多有趣的思考，这可能是量子计算机的第一批应用，即量子计算机如何也能帮助我们理解物理学中的深奥概念。现在它回过头来了，方向逆转了，也许这些计算机可以帮助我们更好地理解基础物理学。哇。哦，这太酷了。是的。有时候，这些事物如何以周期和迭代的方式运行，一个帮助另一个，另一个又反过来帮助，这很有趣，而且那种，另一个又反过来帮助，这很有趣。它有点像，
it sort of, it's kind of fun that way to, to see those cycles happen. Yeah. Sorry to jump into the philosophy of quantum right away. Yeah. We're just going to roll with it. So what I'm going to say is like,
它有点像，看到这些周期发生是很有趣的。是的，抱歉，一开始就跳进了量子的哲学。是的。我们就顺其自然吧。所以我想说的是，
I think a lot of people maybe have those questions that, that you're saying, like I think, and a lot of people listening to this podcast are self-selecting as a potentially the people who ask those questions that you're saying. Like I think, and a lot of people listening to this podcast are self-selecting as potentially the people who ask those questions. But I don't know that everyone pursues the answers with the same, you know, sort of vigor, or you can't pursue every question you have equally, right? Like you would just get nowhere, just navel gaze, right? So like, but I think a lot of people have that. So how for you did you go from like, probably a relatively common question of, you know, why is my screen lighting up to or how is my computer choosing these pixels to like, you know, actually going in and starting to learn physics and quantum mechanics and then rolling that into choosing that to be a career? Do you feel like you sort of was that an intentional thing?
我想很多人可能都有你所说的那些问题，我想，听这个播客的很多人都是潜在的那些会问你所说的问题的人。我想，听这个播客的很多人都是潜在的那些会问这些问题的人。但我不知道每个人都带着同样的，你知道的那种活力去追求答案，或者你不可能同等程度地追求你的每一个问题，对吧？那样你就会一事无成，只会闭门造车，对吧？所以，但我想很多人都有这种想法。那么，对你来说，你是如何从一个可能相对常见的问题——“为什么我的屏幕会亮起”或者“我的计算机是如何选择这些像素的”，转变到“实际深入并开始学习物理学和量子力学，然后将其转化为选择这作为职业”的？你觉得这是一种刻意的安排吗？
Did you sort of like fall into it? Was it just pursuit of those questions? Well, sort of. I mean, you know, I believe that you kind of roll in life. So it wasn't really, I don't see it as a single choice, but I think, you know, things lead to one another. So, you know, I was very interested in physics. I went to study physics. And then once I was exposed, I said to quantum computing, I felt that this is, you know, really a way to look at fundamental physics in a kind of eye-opening way.
你算是顺其自然吗？这只是对这些问题的追求吗？差不多吧。我的意思是，你知道，我相信人生就是随波逐流的。所以这并不是真正的，我不认为这是一个单一的选择，但我认为，你知道，事情是互为因果的。所以，你知道的，我对物理学非常感兴趣。我去学了物理学。然后一旦我接触到，我刚才说的量子计算，我觉得这真的是一种以令人耳目一新的方式看待基础物理学的方法。
But then I actually went and did my PhD, which was in condensed matter physics, which is related to quantum computing, but not exactly. And in parallel, at some point, I also, together with my partner, who is today the CEO of the company, we wanted to be entrepreneurs. So we felt like we got to understand that as well. You know, how do you start a business around technology? And one thing led to another. And then, you know, we realized that the only thing that we really know is quantum stuff.
但后来我实际上去攻读了博士学位，我的研究方向是凝聚态物理学，这与量子计算有关，但又并非完全相同。与此同时，在某个时候，我和我的伙伴——他如今是公司的首席执行官——我们想要成为创业者。所以我们觉得我们也必须了解这一点。你知道，如何围绕技术创业？一事接着一事。然后，你知道，我们意识到我们真正懂的只有量子相关的东西。
So that led to, you know, starting a company in quantum computing. And that's what really got me into, you know, choosing it as a career path, you know. Well, I feel like when most people say, I'm going to make a startup, they mean like, I'm going to make a website. Like I'm going to go and I'm going to download a LAMP stack. And maybe even today I'll run on an AWS, a lot easier today.
所以这导致了，你知道的，创立一家量子计算公司。这才是真正让我选择它作为职业道路的原因，你知道的。嗯，我觉得当大多数人说，我要创业时，他们的意思是，我要做一个网站。就像我要去，我要下载一个LAMP栈。甚至可能今天我会在AWS上运行，现在容易多了。
And again, a lot of people probably have that entrepreneurial, maybe I could do this. Maybe I can make an app or a website. But you said, well, the thing that I know best, I'm going to go start a quantum computing startup. Help me understand that. That feels like such a big leap. Maybe saying condensed matter physics as a PhD. Maybe that's the thing I'm missing. I didn't go that route. But help me understand, is that something you felt that there were particular problems you knew that needed to
再说一次，很多人可能都有那种创业精神，也许我可以做到这一点。也许我可以做一个应用或网站。但你说，我最了解的是，我要去开创一家量子计算初创公司。帮我理解这一点。这感觉像是一个巨大的飞跃。也许说攻读凝聚态物理学博士学位。也许这就是我所缺少的东西。我没有走那条路。但请帮我理解，你是否觉得有些特定的问题你知道需要
be solved? How did you decide that that were particular problems you knew that needed to be solved? How did you decide that that was going to be a successful endeavor? Well, it's an interesting story. So basically, it's never like a straight line, right? So we knew we wanted to start a company. In fact, we didn't start from quantum computing, to be honest. We had lots of ideas, machine learning, you know, like the usual stuff, as you said. But at some point, well, we realized that, well, we realized two things.
被解决？你是如何决定这些是你需要解决的特定问题？你是如何决定这将是一次成功的尝试的？嗯，这是一个有趣的故事。基本上，它从来都不是一条直线，对吧？所以我们知道我们想开一家公司。事实上，说实话，我们并不是从量子计算开始的。我们有很多想法，机器学习，你知道的，就像寻常的东西一样，正如你所说。但在某个时候，好吧，我们意识到，嗯，我们意识到两件事。
First of all, it was about five years ago when quantum, you know, the quantum industry started to evolve. And then there were a few things that happened in the quantum community that kind of got us thinking, oh, well, Quantum is really starting to happen. You know, something is happening. So, and really at the same time, we realized, hey, this is really the only thing that we know. Like we don't really know how to build the best website. That's never stopped anyone before. That's true.
首先，那是大约五年前，量子，你知道，量子产业开始发展的时候。然后量子界发生了一些事情，让我们开始思考，哦，好吧，量子真的开始发生了。你知道，有些事情正在发生。所以，真的在同时，我们意识到，嘿，这真的是我们唯一了解的东西。就像我们真的不知道如何建立最好的网站。这从来没有阻止过任何人。那是真的。
But yeah, we realized this is our expertise. We still didn't know what we wanted to do in quantum. And that's when we called our third co-founder, who was the chief engineer of the company, who did his postdoc at Yale University in one of the top quantum computing groups in the world. And that's when we kind of started sitting together, the three of us, and thinking, you know,
但是，是的，我们意识到这是我们的专长。我们仍然不知道我们想在量子领域做什么。就在那时，我们打电话给我们的第三位联合创始人，他是公司的首席工程师，曾在耶鲁大学的世界顶级量子计算小组之一做过博士后。就在那时，我们三个人开始坐在一起思考，你知道的，
what do we want to do? So Nissin, who went to Yale, also was the first person in history, actually, to perform the first experiment that demonstrated what's called quantum error correction. So Nissim was the first author on a paper that is really one of the biggest milestones, I would say, I don't know,
我们想做什么？所以去过耶鲁的尼辛（Nissim），实际上也是历史上第一个进行实验证明了所谓“量子纠错”的人。所以尼辛是一篇论文的第一作者，我要说，这真的是，我不知道，过去十年该领域最大的里程碑之一，因为量子纠错是业界认为我们应该采取的主流途径，以便扩大量子计算机的规模，构建真正的大规模、全栈量子计算机。尼辛做到了这一点。然后我们坐在一起思考，我们要怎么做？进行这个实验所需的一些东西，我们觉得真的是该领域的瓶颈。这就是所谓的……所以当你看着一台量子计算机时，它是分层构建的。有量子硬件，然后有经典硬件
the last, let's say, decade in the field, because quantum error correction is the kind of like mainstream way that the community believes that we should take in order to scale up quantum computers, build truly large-scale, full-stack quantum computers. So Nissim did that. And then we were sitting together and thinking, what are we going to do? And some of the things that were required to do this experiment were things that we felt are really bottlenecking the field. That's what's called... So when you look at a quantum computer, it's built out of layers. There is the quantum hardware, and then there is the classical hardware
与量子硬件对话。然后是软件。与量子硬件对话的经典硬件不是量子的，但它是非常复杂的经典硬件，需要进行专门设计来与量子硬件对话。我们觉得每个人都在研究量子硬件，但存在许多瓶颈，特别是如果我们展望两、三年、五年、十年后的未来，在这种经典硬件，也就是所谓的控制系统中也是如此。所以我们意识到这是我们想要关注的地方。我们就是这么做的。
that talks to the quantum hardware. And then there is a software. And the classical hardware that talks to the quantum hardware is not quantum, but it's very complicated classical hardware that needs to be specially designed to talk to the quantum hardware. And we felt that everybody's working on the quantum hardware, but there are many bottlenecks, especially if we look at two, three, five years, 10 years from now, in this classical hardware, what's called the control system also. So we realized that's where we want to focus on. And that's what we did.
太棒了。也许把话题稍微拉回一点，我想，正如你所说，我也有这种感觉，虽然我远谈不上是这个领域的专家，但登上主流媒体的文章数量，你知道，某某公司拥有X数量的量子比特新纪录，或者在X时间内实现了量子纠缠，或者所有这些事情，我觉得它们出现得越来越频繁，以至于人们开始说，嘿，也许我们正处于这个的边缘，我不想说这是一场革命，而是一个根本性的转变，它从一个实验
Awesome. Maybe to roll it back a bit, I guess, like you're saying, I have this feeling too, not as being anywhere near the field, but the number of articles that make sort of mainstream media, you know, so-and-so company has X number qubit new record or had a quantum entanglement for X time or all of these things I feel are coming out, you know, more and more frequently where people are beginning to say, hey, maybe we're on the cusp of this, I don't want to say like a revolution, but like this fundamental change where now it goes from an experiment
变成了一个实际可用的东西。我很想听听你的看法，但也许我们可以把它们留到后面再谈。不过，也许把话题拉回到，你知道的，就像开始的时候，我认为人们有点理解，或者他们可能知道，
to a practical usable thing. And I'd love to get your thoughts on there, but maybe we queue them up for sort of later in the thing. But like maybe rolling it back to, you know, kind of like the beginning, I think like people kind of understand or maybe they do the,
二战中建造了埃尼阿克（ENIAC）和密码破译机。但我可以说，一直到我们现在使用的这台计算机，也就是经典的计算机，其架构，我想这个术语应该是冯·诺依曼机。我们有一个CPU，它有寄存器，从内存中拉取数据，并在流水线中处理事情。你知道的，我们所有人，你知道的，上学和学习计算机科学时都学过编程。但与此同时，那些开启这一切的东西来自物理学领域，比如真空管和晶体管。我想这大约是在同一时期，
there was the ENIAC and there were the code breakers in World War II building. But I would say leading up to where we are with the computer we're all using right now, the sort of classical computer, the architecture, I think the term would be the von Neumann machine. We have like a CPU and it has registers and pulls from RAM and processes things in a pipeline. You know, the thing that we all, you know, learn to program when we go to school and learn computer science. But at that same time, like some of those things that unlock that we're coming out of the field of physics, things like vacuum tubes and transistors. And that was around the same
当那个量子东西出现的时候，对我来说，它总是引用尼尔斯·玻尔和阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的话，并不是说我知道什么，但就像是，哦，上帝不掷骰子，对吧？量子力学一定有问题。我认为这可能对他这方面的信念有些肤浅的理解。但我的意思是，你听到过关于这些人的争论，他们今天可以说是聪明人的代名词，对吧？爱因斯坦，尼尔斯·玻尔，这些就像是父亲。
time, I think, like when that quantum stuff, I guess, for me, it's always those quotes back to, you know, Niels Bohr and Albert Einstein, not that I know anything, but it's like, oh, God doesn't play dice with the universe, right? Like quantum mechanics has to be wrong. I think that might be a bit of a superficial take on his belief about that. But I mean, you hear those arguments about these people that today are sort of shortcut names for people who are smart, right? Einstein, Niels Bohr, these are like the father.
这些只是天才的刻板印象，对吧？创造了这些领域，但也许可以给我们讲讲，我们是如何从某种既不是古典的、牛顿的或相对论的物理学，而是这种量子东西，最终让我们走到今天，把这两者融合在一起，也就是量子计算——这信息量有点大，抱歉，是的。不，我的意思是，我认为这是最有趣的话题之一。我的意思是，这个领域的历史非常有趣，因为，正如你所说，我认为量子力学是，
These are just stereo archetypes of like geniuses, right? Creating these fields but maybe kind of walk us how we got from like that there is some kind of physics that isn't classical or or kind of newtonian or relativistic like i'm saying but this quantum thing and how it kind of ended up getting us to where we now kind of fuse these two together quantum computing that was a lot sorry yeah yeah no i mean that mean, I think that's one of the most interesting topics to talk about. I mean, so the history of this field is very interesting because, so as you said, I think that quantum mechanics was, you know,
在计算领域最初的概念被开发的同几个十年里发展起来的。那是独立的。而且，你知道，在80年代的某个时候，这些概念开始融合在一起，我认为这太神奇了。但如果我们回到量子力学的起点，那么量子力学，它真正告诉我们的是，你知道，好吧，所以我们有这个，我们曾经认为的自然所遵循的规律，称之为，如果我们想用编程来谈论，编程
was developed pretty much during the same, you know, several decades where the first concepts in computing were developed. And that was independent. And, you know, sometimes in the 80s, these concepts started to come together, which I think is amazing. But if we go back to the beginning of quantum mechanics, so quantum mechanics, what it really tells us is that, you know, okay, so we have this, what we thought the the laws that we believe that that that the nature obeys um so call it you know if we want to talk in in programming um programming
语言，那么你知道，我能编程什么，你知道，我甚至能编程什么，什么是可能的，你知道，然后量子力学扩展了这一点。以一种当你刚接触时有点难以理解的方式扩展了它。但我认为，它实际上以一种非常优雅的数学方式扩展了它，构成了一个非常完整的数学结构。事实上，可能比经典物理学更完整，尽管仍有许多未知需要去探索。然后人们，你知道的，探索了多年，与此同时，计算机诞生了。我认为这两者，量子力学，你知道，彻底革新了我们对自然的看法，而经典计算机彻底革新了我们的日常生活，
language then you know what what are the what can i program you know what can i even program what's possible you know and then monomechanics it expands that. Expands it in ways that are a bit weird to grasp when you learn about it. But it actually expands it, I think, in a very elegant mathematical way that makes very complete mathematical structure. Maybe more complete, in fact, than classical physics, even though there is still a lot to discover. And then so people, you know, explore that for many years, while at the same time, kind of computers happened. And I think these two, so quantum mechanics, you know, completely revolutionized how we think about nature, while classical computers completely revolutionized our day-to-day lives,
对吧？以及我们能对自然做什么，对经典自然做什么。计算机彻底革新了我们的日常生活，对吧？我们能对自然做什么，对经典自然做什么。然后在70年代末80年代初的某个时候，有些人开始思考，好吧，这些概念，你知道，它们在某种意义上是相关的。你知道，它来自几个方向。一个是，我能用经典计算机模拟一个量子系统吗？事实证明这非常非常困难。所以如果你试图模拟某些量子力学系统，在计算机上需要永远的时间。所以你问，
right? And what we can do with nature, with the classical nature. Computers completely revolutionized our day-to-day lives, right? What we can do with nature, with the classical nature. And then sometimes in the late 70s, beginning of 80s, some people started thinking, okay, these concepts, you know, they're related in some sense. You know, it came from several directions. One was, can I simulate a quantum system using classical computers? And that turns out to be very, very difficult. So if you're trying to simulate certain quantum mechanical systems, it just takes forever on a computer. So you ask,
好吧，那么大自然模拟自身非常快。为什么我不能用计算机来做呢？你知道，我们有图灵机的概念，你知道，它是一台等同于所有其他计算机器的机器，对吧？但是不，我无法用量子力学做到这一点。所以立刻，嗯，不完全是立刻，它需要理查德·费曼（Richard Feynman），他是那些听起来很聪明的人之一。所以他提出了这个问题，你知道，好吧，我们不能用经典计算机有效地模拟自然。但他还采取了下一步，他问，那么我们是否应该构建一个能够为我们模拟自然量子系统？这就是量子计算机的最初概念。保罗·贝诺夫（Paul Benoff）也发表过关于计算机的演讲
okay, so nature simulates itself very quickly. So why can't I do it with a computer? You know, we have this concept of a Turing machine, you know, that is a machine that's equivalent to all other computation machines, right? But no, I cannot do it with quantum mechanics. So immediately, well, not immediately, it required Richard Feynman, which is one of those people
作为物理系统。将计算机视为物理系统，计算机在发热方面的基本局限性是什么，经典计算机是不可逆的这一事实。你无法逆转计算，而量子力学实际上是可逆的。量子力学中发生的一切，你都可以逆转。所以所有这些概念促使人们开始思考，我们能否构建一台本质上是量子的且通用的计算机器？第一个真正将其带入计算机科学语言的人，我认为是埃利泽·多伊奇（Eliezer Deutsch），他证明了存在一个
that sounds like someone smart. And so he asked this question, you know, okay, so we cannot simulate nature efficiently with classical computers. But he took the next step also, and he asked, so should we build a quantum system that can simulate nature for us? And that is sort of the first concept of a quantum computer. It was also Paul Benoff that was giving talks about the computer
通用量子计算机的概念，它基本上可以模拟任何其他量子系统，就像图灵机对任何其他经典系统所做的那样，对吧？这有点扩展了所有这些概念。这里有一个很好的，有几个，我有很多问题，但我的意思是，我觉得不，那是一个棒极了的概述。你刚才说的一件事我以前其实没听过，但我想现在我正在脑子里琢磨它，那就是，我想也许，也许人们不知道，但你提到的这件事——
as a physical system. Thinking about the computer as a physical system, what are the fundamental limitations of a computer in terms of generating heat, the fact that classical computers are irreversible. You cannot reverse the computation while quantum mechanics is actually reversible. Everything that happens in quantum mechanics, you can reverse. So all of these concepts sort of brought people to start thinking about, can we build a machine that is by nature quantum and is a general computation machine? And the first person to actually bring it down to the language of computer science, I think was Eliezer Deutsch, who proved that there is a concept
普通计算机的不可逆性，对吧？我想，如果你有，如果你想想作为基础的逻辑门，我要试一下，你可以告诉我我说得对不对，但像有一个CPU，CPU由逻辑门组成。如果你把，你知道，两个比特送入一个与门（AND），或者一个或门（OR），1和0，1和1，0和0。然后你得到，你知道，真值表，另一边出来的是什么，或门输出端的1并不能告诉你输入是什么。所以一定量的信息在某种程度上丢失了。我认为这与麦克斯韦妖（Maxwell's demon）和这种，你知道，预言机允许的，
of a universal quantum computer that could basically simulate any other quantum system, just like kind of a Turing machine does to any other classical system, right? And that sort of just expands all these concepts well there's a great tour there's a couple i have a lot of questions but i mean i think like no that was that was awesome overview one thing that you said i actually hadn't heard before but i guess like now i'm trying to puzzle it out in my head which is i think maybe maybe people don't know but this thing you mentioned
信息论有关，就像你在销毁信息一样，部分信息丢失了，因为这些东西是不可逆的。而且它试图设定，我猜，计算某些方程所需能量的下限，因为你有这种信息量的损失。并不是说你可以按那个计算，就像我们实际上，它消耗的能量远远多于我们，多于我们通过这种方式计算出来的能量。但有这个想法。所以也许人们以前没听说过这个。但是你知道，我认为如果你学习计算机科学以及CPU架构的工作原理以及绕过热力学极限这类想法，你就会接触到这一点。但我其实没有听过你刚才说的，也就是量子计算机是可逆的，这个想法
about irreversibility of normal computers, right? I think that when you have, if you think about logic gates, which underpin this, I'm going to try, you can tell me if I get it right or wrong, but like have like a CPU and the CPU is composed of logic gates. And if you send, you know, two bits into an AND gate, you're an OR gate, one and zero, one and one, zero and zero. And then you get, you know, the truth table, what comes out the other side, that having a one on the output of an org gate doesn't tell you what the inputs were. So some amount of information is sort of lost. I think that's related to sort of that Maxwell's demon and this like, you know, Oracle allowing, you know, and
实际上它们没有同样的问题。是的，完全如此。让我们从经典计算机开始。经典计算机有，你知道的，它们有两个主要的构建模块，对吧？我们有比特，那是我们存储信息的方式；然后我们有门，那是我们处理信息的方式，对吧？所以每个程序，本质上，在一天结束时，从根本上讲，是一系列在大量比特上执行的门操作，对吧？正如你所说，这些门，至少我们现在做事的方式是，是的，它们是不可逆的。所以我们在过程中会丢失信息。这实际上会产生热量，这就回到了，你知道的，计算机作为物理系统的概念。每当你丢失
the information theory, like you're destroying that information, some of the information is lost, because these things aren't reversible. And it tries to set, I guess, a lower bound on the amount of energy it takes to compute certain equations, because you have this amount of information loss. And it's not that you can compute it for that, like we actually, it takes way more energy than we than energy than we are calculating that way to do it. But there's this idea. So maybe folks hadn't heard about that. But you know, I think you get into that if you study computer science and how CPU architectures work and sort of ideas for getting around thermal limits and these kinds of things. But I actually hadn't heard what you were saying, which is quantum computers are reversible that this idea
信息时，是的，你就会产生热量。顺便说一句，我们现在距离这个极限还非常遥远，我认为我们距离达到这个目标还有好几个数量级——所以经典计算机产生的大部分热量，远远不是来自于此。但这设定了我们目前如何制造经典计算机的基本限制。人们开始询问你是否可以构建可逆的经典或量子系统。现在，量子系统，它们用量子比特（qubit）的概念取代了比特的概念，量子比特不是一个只能是0或1的系统。它实际上可以以一定的权重同时处于0和1的状态。我们称这些为振幅。
that actually they don't have that same issue yeah exactly so let's start from classical computers classical computers have you know they have two main building blocks right we have the bit that's how we or the bits that's how we store information then we have the gates uh which is how we process information right and so every program, essentially, at the end of the day, fundamentally, is a sequence of gates performed on a bunch of bits, right? And as you said, those gates are, the way we do it at least now is, yeah, they're irreversible. So we lose information along the way. And that actually generates heat that goes back to you know computer computer as a physical system whenever you lose
所以我们说它处于0和1的叠加态。它是，我不知道，一点点0和很多1，反之亦然。事实上，这些振幅，这些波也可以是负数。所以它在0状态时可以是负0.1，而在1状态时可以是正0.9。但随后你用量子门对这些量子比特进行操作。量子门，是的，它们总是可逆的。所以我们称之为酉变换（unitary transformation）。因此，每个量子门都有，你知道，一定数量的比特输入，相同数量的比特必须输出。并且在整个量子电路中都是如此，因为它是可逆的。所以这是首先要证明的，量子计算机可以做经典计算机能做的一切。而且它确实可以。
information yeah you generate it yes we are very far away from this limit by the way right now I think we're several orders of magnitudes from reaching you know so most of the heat that the classical computer generates by far is not coming from that but that sets sort of the fundamental limits of how we do currently classical computer. And people started asking whether you could build classical or quantum systems that are reversible. Now, quantum systems, they replace the notion of a bit with the notion of a qubit, which is not a system that can be either zero or one. It can actually be in both zero and one at the same time with certain weights. We call those amplitudes.
这是一个很好的回答。我正要问。答案是它可以，这也向你展示了你可以构建一台可逆的机器，它的作用是，你知道的，等同于图灵机。所以你可以做到这一点，这本身就是一个伟大且非常有趣的理念，与量子计算不一定非得有直接关联。所以你可以构建一台可逆的机器，做任何不可逆机器做的事情。
So we say it's in a superposition of zero and one. It's, I don't know, a little bit in zero and a lot in one and vice versa. In fact, those amplitudes, these waves can also be negative numbers. So it can be minus 0.1 in the zero state and whatever, plus 0.9 in the one state. But then you operate on these qubits with quantum gates. And quantum gates, yes, they're always reversible. So we call this unitary transformation. But so every quantum gate has, you know, a certain number of bits going in, the same number of bits need to go out. And along the entire quantum circuit do because it's reversible. So that was the first thing to prove that a quantum computer could do everything that a classical computer can do. And it can.
除此之外，我们还可以证明，由于量子性质，实际上因为这些振幅不仅仅是复数，我们还可以利用这一点，做一台经典机器做不到的事情。所以，是的，我关于量子比特也有成吨的问题。但实际上，奇怪的是，我要暂时跳过这些，来问问关于门的问题，因为所以我想，在这个旅程中，我们讨论了逻辑门，大多数人都看过“或”门的图片，我不应该说大多数人，希望你看过，如果没有的话去谷歌一下，你就会看到那张图片，但它可能也是，15分钟你就可以向
That's a good answer. I was going to ask. The answer is that yes, it can, which also shows you that you could build a reversible machine that does, that's, you know, equivalent to a Turing machine. So you could do that, which is a great, I think, very interesting concept by itself, unrelated to necessarily, you know, quantum computing. So you can build a reversible machine that does whatever an irreversible machine does.
某人解释如何以某些方式对半导体进行掺杂，并让他们推导出一个较高的电压电势和一个较低电压电势以及第三个，你知道的，一个“非”门或“或”门或“与”门是如何工作的。所以也许人们不知道，我不应该假设，但是，你知道，我觉得那是很容易获得的。我没有半导体物理学的背景，但我作为一个当今领域的从业者，有一个大致的工作理解，那就是有这些半导体，有门，它们被掺杂了，它们是，你知道的，我——这需要我花很长时间，但你可以坐下来画出逻辑门并弄清楚它们，一路推导出来。但当你提到你有一个
And then in addition to that, we can also show that because of the quantum nature, actually because these amplitudes are not just complex numbers, we can also take advantage of this and do more than a classical machine can do. So, yeah, I have a ton of questions about qubits as well. But actually, oddly, I'm going gonna skip those for a second and ask about the gates because so i guess like on this journey we talk about logic gates and most people have seen the picture of an ore and i shouldn't say most people hopefully you have if not go google it and you just sort of see the picture but it's also maybe you know 15 minutes you could explain
处于叠加态的量子比特，然后是一个量子计算机门，我甚至不知道——那是吗？那是什么门？它是一个物理实体吗？它是半——比如，那到底长什么样？是的，这是一个很好的问题。人们对此谈论得还不够多，所以它听起来像是一个迷雾中的东西，但实际上它相当直观。它的工作原理是——好吧，今天量子比特有不同的实现方式，但大多数量子比特是我所谓的“静态量子比特”（stationary qubits）。所以这是一个坐在空间中某个地方的物理系统，你知道的，例如，它可以是被激光束捕获的离子或原子。想象一下，你有一排离子坐在
someone like dope semiconductors in certain ways and have them reason through how like a higher voltage potential and a lower voltage potential and a third, you know, and how a not works or how an or works or how an and works. So maybe people don't know that I shouldn't assume, but like, you know, I feel like that's readily accessible. Like I don't have a background in semiconductor physics, but like I have a rough working understanding as a practitioner in the field today that like there are these semiconductors and there's gates and they're doped and they're you know how i i it would take me a long time but you could sit down and sort of draw gates and figure it out and work your way through it but when you say that you have a qubit
真空室里，这些离子就是量子比特。实际上，量子比特的0和1是电子可以处于的两个轨道。如果你还记得高中化学，你有一个原子。
in a superposition and then a quantum computer gate i just don't even know like is that it what is that gate is it a physical thing is it semi kind of like how like what does that actually look like yeah uh that's a great question people don't talk about it enough so it sounds like uh so it sounds you know inside a cloud of fog but it's actually pretty straightforward so the the way it works so okay there are different implementations of qubits today but but most most qubits are what i call stationary qubits so this is a physical system that sits somewhere in space you know it could be for example an ion or an atom that's trapped with laser beams so imagine you have a bunch of ions sitting in a row, some vacuum chamber, and these ions are the qubits. Actually, what the zero and one of the qubit are two orbitals in which the electron can be. So if you remember from high school chemistry, you have an atom.
所以在内部你有一个电子，电子可以四处盘旋，但实际上它可以坐在不同的轨道上，对吧？它可以是一个轨道或另一个轨道，但它也可以处于这些轨道的叠加态。所以这就是我们的量子比特，基本上。我们取其中两个轨道，其中一个是我们的0状态，另一个是我们的1状态，好的？所以我们有两个状态。现在，正如你所说，我们要开始对系统应用门了。现在，你知道物理学家喜欢发射激光束。所以我们这里也这样做。于是我们发射激光束。在这里，我实际上是有原因地这样做的。
So inside you have an electron and the electron can be, it circles around, but really it can sit on different orbitals, right? It could be one orbital or the other, but it can also be in a superposition of those orbitals. So this is our qubit, basically. We take two of these orbitals, and one of them is our zero, and one of them is our one state, okay? So we have two states. And now, as you said, we want to start to apply gates to the system. Now, you know that physicists like to shoot laser beams. So we do it as well here. And so we shoot a laser beam. Here, I actually do it for a reason.
我们向离子发射激光束。这实际上导致电子从一个轨道移动到另一个轨道，好的？如果我们用正确的方式做到这一点，正确塑造激光束的形状，它也可以使电子进入叠加态，并且它基本上应用了我们想要的门，好的。我们可以通过对撞击这些离子的激光束进行不同的整形来应用任何量子门。好的。但是，如果你要对一个进行“非”操作，或者你只对一个执行，它必须与两个相互作用，对吧？
So we shoot a laser beam on the ion. And that actually causes the electron to move from one orbital to another, okay? And if we do it just in the right way, we shape the laser beam correctly, it can also make the electron go into a superposition, and it basically applies the gate that we want, okay? So we can apply any quantum gate by different shaping of these laser beams that hit these ions. Okay. So it has to interact with two though, right? If you're going to have like not operation on one or you only perform it on one.
我的意思是，这里的门是一个单独的量子比特，你应用像——也许我漏掉了。也许我……不，不，不。完美的问题。这就是。我刚才描述的准确地说是一个单量子比特门。好的，好的。所以当你考虑它时，
Like I guess, is it gate here, a single qubit and you're applying like, maybe I lost it. Maybe I... No, no, no. Perfect question. So that's that. Now what I described was exactly a single qubit gate. Okay, okay. So when you think about it, so think about the qubit.
考虑量子比特的一种方法是，一个比特是0和1，对吧？所以你可以有一个指向下或向上的箭头，是的？一个量子比特就像一个箭头，可以指向球体表面的任何地方，好的？好的。这实际上是一个准确的数学描述。所以我可以将量子比特的状态描述为球体上的一个点。是的？因此，与经典比特形成对比的是，你唯一能执行的单比特门是“非”门（not gate），对吧？
One way to think about the qubit is, so a bit is zero and one, right? So you can have an arrow that points down or up, yeah? A qubit is like an arrow that can point anywhere on the surface of a sphere, okay? Okay. So that actually, this is an accurate mathematical description. So I can describe the state of the qubit as a point on the sphere. Yeah? So in contrast to the classical bit where the only single bit gate that you can perform is a not gate, right?
仅仅是从0到1，1到0，嗯，单量子比特门，我们基本上有无限数量的单量子比特门，因为，是的，我们可以对球体表面执行任何旋转，对吧？嗯，所以——因此，激光束的功率以及我们施加到这个量子比特、离子内部电子上的激光相位，将决定我们围绕球体旋转的速度。而相位将决定我们基本上是围绕哪个轴旋转。然后你真的可以在球体上创造任何旋转。哦，太迷人了。是的。
Just from zero to one one to zero um a a single qubit gate we have basically infinite number of single qubit gates because yeah so we can perform any rotation on the surface of the sphere right um so so actually the power of the laser beam as well as the phase of the laser that we apply to this qubit, to this electron inside the ion, that's going to determine how fast we are rotating around the sphere. And the phase will determine basically around which axis we're rotating. So then you can really create any rotation on the sphere. Oh, fascinating. Yeah.
而这仅仅是一个单量子比特门。当然，正如你所说，现在我需要，当然我们希望量子比特相互作用。我们希望，这是量子领域中最重要的事情之一，因为我们希望创造纠缠。我们希望整个系统进入这种单一的量子状态。为此，我们需要双量子比特门。但是，你知道，这是一个类似的概念，你用一些激光束击中这些离子，并使它们产生相互作用。所以你必须
And this is just a single qubit gate. And of course, as you said, now I need to, okay, of course we want qubits to interact. We want to, this is one of the most important things in quantum because we want to create entanglement. We want to have the entire system go into this like single quantum state. And for that, we need two qubit gates. But that's, you know, it's a similar idea, you hit those ions with some laser beams, and you bring them to interaction. So you have to
有某种它们进行交互的物理机制。但这种物理系统机制取决于，你知道的，外部力量，比如这些外部磁场、电磁场等等。这是关于离子的，但我可以用超导量子比特做同样的事情，这是另一个领先的平台，在那里，你知道的，你用超导材料（比如铝）制造一个小电路。当你把它冷却到非常低的温度时，它开始表现出量子力学特性，然后你实际上可以创造一个有点像离子的系统。实际上，它是一个电路，是一个我们可以在芯片上制造的宏观电路，
have some physical mechanism in which they interrupt. But this physical system mechanism depends, you know, on external forces like these external magnetic fields, electromagnetic fields, and so on. And this was about ions, but I could do the same with superconducting qubits, which is another leading platform where, you know, you create a small circuit from superconducting material like aluminum, for instance. And when you cool it down to very low temperatures, it starts to behave quantum mechanically, and then you actually can create a system which is kind of like the ion. It actually, it's a circuit, it's a macroscopic circuit that we can fabricate on a chip,
就像你在芯片上制造晶体管一样。你在芯片上制造它，但它就像一个“人造原子”，因为它具有那些能量级，量子能级，就像离子中的轨道一样。我可以发射微波。现在，它不是激光脉冲。它是微波脉冲，因为能量不同，但概念是一样的。我通过连接到这个芯片的导线发射微波脉冲，
just like you fabricate transistors on a chip. You fabricate it on a chip, but it's like an artificial atom in the sense that it has those energy levels, quantum energy levels, just like the orbitals in the ion. And I could send a microwave. Now, it's not a laser pulse. It's a microwave pulse because it's just different energies, but it's the same concept. I shoot a microwave pulse through a wire that's connected to this chip,
这个微波脉冲基本上击中了那些量子比特，那些超导量子比特，并执行了这些门，我可以执行双量子比特门、单量子比特门，然后我可以创造所谓的“通用门集”（universal set of gates），这类似于经典计算中的与非门（NAND gate），它表明从离散数量的量子门中，我可以实际创造出量子计算的整个世界。好吧，你刚刚为我们把它们都造出来了。我的意思是，你说了许多相当深奥的事情。
and this microwave pulse basically hits those qubits, those superconducting qubits, and perform the gates, and I can perform two-qubit gates, single-qubit gates, and then I could create what's called the universal set of gates, which is a similar concept to the NAND gate in classical computing, which says that from a discrete number of quantum gates, I could actually create the universe of quantum computing. Well, you just built them all for us. I mean, you said a lot of things that are pretty sophisticated.
我不想现在就深入探讨，但我看到了你关于这个的控制系统的设置，你知道的，激光器、控制相位和强度，我假设还有频率。而且，我的意思是，我想我们要，我看到了这个的发展方向。但在我们去那里之前，你提到有类似于超导的，有离子的，有不同的方法。听起来你是在说，目前还不清楚哪一个一定更好。有没有正在探索的权衡？比如，一个更适合这个，另一个更适合那个，还是说每个人都在竞相制造出第一个可行的产品？
I don't want to get there quite yet, but I'm seeing your setup about the control systems for this, you know, lasers and controlling phase and intensities and I assume frequencies. And like, I mean, I think we're going to, I see where this is headed. But before we go there, you mentioned that there's sort of like superconducting, that there's ion, there's like different approaches. And it sounds like you're saying that it's not clear yet, necessarily, that one is better. Are there trade offs that are being explored? Like, one is better for this thing, the other is better for this, or it's just, everybody's just in a race to build the first one that works?
我不想那么快就聊到那里，但我看到了你关于这方面控制系统的架构，你知道的，激光、控制相位和强度，我猜还有频率。我的意思是，我觉得我们要，我看出这是要往哪儿发展了。但在我们去那儿之前，你提到过有超导之类的，有离子阱，有不同的方法。听起来你是说，现在还不一定清楚哪一种更好。大家在探索权衡取舍吗？比如，一种更适合这个，另一种更适合那个，还是说，每个人都只是在争分夺秒地建造出第一个能运行的系统？
Yeah, exactly. I mean, we don't have kind of the silicon transistor yet of quantum. So there is a race now between many different kinds of qubits. I'd say there's at least five, six leading candidates to be the kind of dominating qubit. So that's happening right now. And some of them have, yes, advantages in some areas and some have advantages in other areas. So it's hard to say who's going to win this race. And there could be also combinations.
对，完全正确。我的意思是，我们还没有造出量子领域的硅晶体管。因此，目前许多不同类型的量子比特之间存在着竞争。我想至少有五、六个主要的候选者有望成为主导的量子比特。所以这一切正在发生。其中一些确实在某些领域有优势，而另一些在其他领域有优势。所以很难说谁会赢得这场竞赛。而且也可能会有组合。
So when you think about a modern computer, actually, there are many different ways in which we implement bits. So some implementations are better to create, you know, a hard drive, and some implementations are better to create the bits that go into the CPU and so on. So it could be that in the future, we're also going to see some hybrids, you know, quantum computers that are based on different types of qubits. Yeah, I never thought about it that way, but I guess you're absolutely right. Like an SSD or flash and DRAM and a computer all have like slightly different kind of mechanisms for representing like zero or one. So, yeah, I guess from that standpoint, yeah, you're absolutely right.
所以当你想到现代计算机时，实际上，我们实现比特的方式有很多种。有些实现方式更适合用来制造硬盘，而有些实现方式更适合用来制造进入CPU的比特等等。所以在未来，我们很可能会看到一些混合架构，你知道的，基于不同类型量子比特的量子计算机。是的，我以前从没这样想过，但我想你是对的。就像电脑里的固态硬盘或闪存和DRAM，它们表示零或一的机制都有点不同。所以，从这个角度来看，是的，你绝对是对的。
And they have tradeoffs. It's not that only one is correct. There's a variety of reasons you may choose one or the other. Right. I can give you an example, for example. So a trap ion system is the lifetimes or the time that the qubit can actually preserve quantum information are much longer than superconducting qubits. But superconducting qubits are much, much faster. So you can perform the gates about three orders of magnitude faster. So, you know, so that's a huge advantage, right? Because, I mean, okay, let's say, okay, so it's true that a quantum computer should be at the end of the day, exponentially faster. And we don't care about those three factors, you know, the theories, they don't care about those three factors you know the theory the theories they don't care about these three factors because it's not fundamentally a part of you know whether it's in this computational class or another but but these pre-factors matter like
而且它们各有权衡。并不是说只有一种是正确的。你选择其中一种或另一种有各种各样的原因。没错。我可以举个例子。比如，离子阱系统的寿命，也就是量子比特实际保存量子信息的时间，要比超导量子比特长得多。但超导量子比特要快得多。所以你可以把门操作的速度提升大约三个数量级。所以，你知道的，这是一个巨大的优势，对吧？因为，我的意思是，好吧，比方说，好吧，确实量子计算机最终应该呈指数级更快。我们不在乎那三个前置因子，你知道的，理论家们，他们不在乎那三个前置因子，你知道的，理论，理论家们不在乎这三个前置因子，因为从根本上讲，这并不属于它是否属于某个计算类别的一部分，但是，但是这些前置因子确实很重要，
if we build the first quantum computers that can actually do something useful and it can do something that a classical computer does in 10 days maybe it can do it in one day well that's great i solve a problem you know 10 times Well, that's great. I solve a problem, you know, 10 times faster, but that's on a superconducting qubit computer. On a trapped ion computer, it will take a thousand days, right? So at least for the first, you know, decade of the field, I think that this is going to be important. But then on the other end, as I said, so maybe some qubits are better for memory and some for computation and so on.
如果我们制造出第一台真正能做点有用事情的量子计算机，并且它能完成经典计算机需要10天才能完成的事情，也许它一天就能完成，那太好了，我解决了一个问题，你知道，快了10倍，好吧，那太好了。我解决了一个问题，你知道的，快了10倍，但那是建立在超导量子比特计算机上的。在一台离子阱计算机上，这可能需要一千天，对吧？所以至少在该领域的前十年，我认为这将会很重要。但另一方面，正如我所说，也许有些量子比特更适合做内存，有些更适合做计算，诸如此类。
I know you already kind of, I guess, seeded my thoughts there, but the error correcting, so everyone kind of knows like in a normal, or maybe not, I keep saying everyone. I feel like I have been well, like heard it over and over again in a normal computer, like, oh, you can have a cosmic ray comes in and strikes your memory and flips a bit.
我知道你之前已经，我猜，在那里埋下了伏笔，但纠错机制，所以每个人都知道，在普通计算机中，或者也许不知道，我一直在说每个人。我觉得我已经，好吧，在普通计算机里，这句话我已经听过无数遍了，比如，哦，可能会有一束宇宙射线进来，击中你的内存，导致比特翻转。
But we also know like, you know, electrostatic discharge or, you know, just like depending on time, something like DRAM needs to be refreshed or you can have corruption. So I think we tend to not think about errors too much, except when your hard drive gets corrupted. But like you tend not to think about, you know, I guess errors too much except when your hard drive gets corrupted but like you tend not to think about you know i guess errors too much and it gets handled and there you know you learn about like crc checks or hashes you know things that are either tell you if there is a problem or tell you how to fix the problem is that's like kind of like the classical computer thing um when you're talking about quantum computers i assume it's sort of analogous. Is it like lifetime measured in units
但我们也知道，比如说，静电放电，或者只是根据时间的不同，像DRAM这样的东西需要刷新，否则可能会发生损坏。所以我想我们往往不会过多去想错误，除非你的硬盘损坏了。但是，嗯，你往往不会去想，你知道的，我猜除了你的硬盘损坏之外，你不会太去考虑错误，但是，嗯，你会倾向于不怎么去考虑，你知道的，我猜是错误，然后它会被处理掉，在那里，你知道，你会了解像CRC校验或哈希之类的东西，你知道的，那些要么告诉你是否有问题，要么告诉你如何修复问题的东西，这有点像是经典计算机的东西，嗯，当你谈论量子计算机时，我假设这有点类似。它的寿命是以时间单位来衡量的，
of time or a number of operations? Like what are the things that cause you to sort of, you talk about like very cold temperatures and high vacuum. So I start to think about things like, you know, well, you can't really have it exactly pure. So there's always like something floating around, you're not exactly cold enough. Is it just system, things like that? Or is there like more fundamental things that are creeping in that cause you to kind of error out and not get the thing you thought you were going to get? No. So, yeah, the errors can come from many different mechanisms and sources of noise. As you said, it could come from simply the fact that there is a finite temperature.
还是以操作次数来衡量的？比如，是什么原因导致你，你谈到过极低温度和高真空。所以我开始想到一些事情，比如，嗯，你不可能做到绝对纯净。所以总是有一些杂质四处飘浮，你的温度还不够低。仅仅是系统层面的问题，诸如此类吗？还是有更根本的东西在潜入，导致你出错，而没有得到你以为会得到的那个东西？不是的。所以，是的，错误可以来自许多不同的机制和噪声源。正如你所说，它可能仅仅来自于存在有限温度这一事实。
So, you know, finite temperature tells you that, okay, if you're in this energy state, you could jump to a higher level energy state. So you try to isolate more, to cool down more. As you said, cosmic rays or even photons that wander around could give you errors and then the control system itself can give you errors as well because we're not sending exactly the right pulses that
所以，你知道，有限温度告诉你，好吧，如果你处于这个能态，你可能会跃迁到更高能级的状态。所以你要试图更多地隔离，更多地冷却。正如你所说，宇宙射线甚至是四处游荡的光子都可能给你带来错误，然后控制系统本身也会带来错误，因为我们发送的脉冲并不完全是我们
we want to send to the system and there's noise, there's electronic noise coming from the classical electronics and so on and so forth so there are many, so I think there isn't exactly a fundamental thing and I think we could build better and better qubits in the future. I think that's super important to do that. There is, however, a challenge in the fact that on one hand, you want to isolate.
想要发送给系统的脉冲，并且存在噪声，来自经典电子设备的电子噪声等等，所以有许多，所以我觉得并没有一个单一的根本性问题，而且我认为未来我们可以制造出越来越好的量子比特。我认为这样做超级重要。然而，这里存在一个挑战：一方面，你希望进行隔离。
So for a system to be quantum and to be protected from the noise from the environment you want to isolate it from the environment right but then on the other side on the other end we do want to speak to it from the control system right this laser puzzle so we do want to couple it to the environment so there is this challenge where you on one hand you want to couple it to the control system but you you want to isolate it from everything else and even you even from the control system, but you want to isolate it from everything else. And even from the control system, you want to isolate it when you're not sending the passes that you're intending to see. So it's an engineering problem. I wouldn't say it's a fundamental issue, but it is, I think, a big challenge that's going to be important. And again, one of the main ways to deal with it
因此，要使系统保持量子态并免受来自环境噪声的干扰，你希望将它与环境隔离，对吧？但另一方面，在另一端，我们确实希望从控制系统与它对话，对吧，比如这些激光脉冲，所以我们确实希望将它与环境耦合。因此这里存在这样一个挑战：一方面你希望将它与控制系统耦合，但你又希望将它与所有其他东西隔离，甚至连控制系统也要隔离，但你希望将它与所有其他东西隔离。甚至连控制系统，在你没有发送你打算发送的脉冲时，你也希望将它与控制系统隔离。所以这是一个工程问题。我不会说这是一个根本性的问题，但我认为这是一个非常重要的大挑战。而且再次强调，处理它的主要方法之一
is to say, okay, I'm good enough now. Let me just now start doing quantum error correction. And that basically deals with this noise. Because what quantum error correction does, which I think is interesting to note, is that it digitizes the quantum information to some extent. So I talked about this qubit, which is kind of like a vector on a sphere, right? So it's, you think about it, it's an analog system. And one of the things that bother people is that, okay, so how can we build this thing? You know, it's analog. So I can have an error, which is a tiny angle that the qubit is not exactly, you know, pointing down, it's pointing
就是说，好吧，我现在已经够好了。现在让我开始进行量子纠错。这基本上就是用来应对噪声的。因为量子纠错所做的事情——我认为这一点很值得指出——是在某种程度上将量子信息数字化。所以我之前谈到了这个量子比特，它有点像球面上的一个向量，对吧？所以它是，你仔细想想，它是一个模拟系统。让人感到困扰的事情之一就是，好吧，我们到底该怎么造这个东西？你知道的，它是模拟的。所以我会遇到一个错误，也就是量子比特并没有精确指向下方，而是偏离了一个微小的角度，指向了
one angle to the right. So that's a challenge. But quantum error correction actually allows you to digitize those errors. It digitizes the errors. So when you do quantum error correction, you either get an error with a very low probability or you don't get an error at all. And that's very important because it kind of does what we do with digital. It kind of does what we do with digital electronics where we're protected from a
右侧的一个角度。所以这是一个挑战。但量子纠错实际上允许你将这些错误数字化。它将错误数字化。因此，当你进行量子纠错时，你要么遇到概率极低的错误，要么根本遇不到错误。这非常重要，因为它有点像我们在数字技术中所做的事情。它有点像我们在数字电子技术中所做的事情，我们在一定的阈值内受到保护，
certain threshold and then it's very hard to get errors you know so you kind of can lower and lower and lower the error rates to as much as you want basically Do those errors creep in like you mentioned the qubits needing to be in superposition and then they can sort of
然后错误就很难发生了，所以你可以把错误率降得越来越低，基本上可以降到你想要的任意程度。这些错误会潜入进来吗？就像你提到的量子比特需要处于叠加态，然后它们可能会
I guess like fall out of superposition during the calculation or is it more i don't know i don't know if that's the right analogy but like a measurement thing just like when you take a measurement there's some noise and so if the thing isn't exactly where you thought it was and they're just sort of measurement errors yes all of the things yeah so it's both so the so when we say that the the system falls from a superposition, one of the reasons it falls from a superposition is because it interacts with something in the environment. And in some sense, you can think about it as sort of
我猜就像在计算过程中脱离叠加态，或者更像是一个，我不知道，我不知道这算不算正确的类比，但就像测量一样，当你进行测量时会有一些噪声，如果那个东西并不完全处于你想象的位置，然后这只是某种测量错误？是的，所有这些因素都有，是的。所以两者皆有。因此，当我们说系统从叠加态中跌落时，它跌落自叠加态的原因之一是它与环境中的某些东西发生了相互作用。从某种意义上说，你可以把它想象成
it's being measured by the environment. So the environment kind of measures the system and sucks the quantumness out of it because it kind of collapses it to one of the states right and we don't know to which one i mean if we if we could then measure the environment maybe we we know to which one so we can fix it but but but we don't so the so whenever we get coupled to the environment we kind of get get get measured by the environment and that and that is one reason for the noise then you you also have Ls.
它正在被环境所测量。所以环境有点像在测量系统，并把它的量子特性给吸干了，因为它把系统坍缩到了其中一个状态，对吧？而且我们不知道是哪一个——我的意思是，如果我们能测量环境，也许我们就知道是哪一个，所以我们就能修复它，但是我们不能。因此，每当我们与环境耦合时，我们就会被环境所测量，这就是产生噪声的一个原因。然后你还会有
When you measure the system, maybe you measure it in the wrong way. So these are called readout Ls. So you get all kinds of Ls you have to deal with. So we've been talking about, I guess, the fundamental qubits and gates. And I'm not going to ask you to describe algorithms that you compose from those things. But they exist, as you mentioned. You've proven that you have the equivalent of like the fundamental one. So you could just, I guess, as a backstop build, like the naive old way of doing things in the new approach. But you also mentioned this sort of like trying to use them to do, I guess, I would kind of take it as like fundamentally quantum approaches to solving problems. And I, you know, I mentioned even in the opening, like, you know,
当你测量系统时，也许你用错误的方式测量了它。这些被称为读出错误。所以你会遇到各种各样必须处理的错误。我们一直在讨论，我猜是基本的量子比特和逻辑门。我不会要求你描述由这些东西组合而成的算法。但它们确实存在，正如你所提到的。你已经证明了你拥有类似基本算法的等价物。所以你可以，我猜作为后备方案，在新方法中构建那种幼稚的旧方法。但你也提到了这种试图用它们来做事的尝试，我猜，我会把它理解为解决问题的根本性的量子方法。而且，你知道，我甚至在开场时就提到过，你知道，
Hey, we're going to factor large prime numbers. Everyone says, Oh, quantum computers are just going to like factor large prime numbers. All encryption is going to be broken or at least the ones that rely on, you know, prime testing or factorization. But then you mentioned something which I have, I've heard before, but I never really kind of understood, which is actually trying to have the quantum computers simulate quantum computers as like a proof that you're doing like a fundamentally different thing.
嘿，我们要对大质数进行因式分解。每个人都说，哦，量子计算机就是去对大质数进行因式分解。所有的加密技术都将被破解，或者至少是那些依赖于素性测试或因式分解的加密技术。但随后你提到了某件事，我以前听说过，但我从来没有真正理解过，那就是实际上试图让量子计算机来模拟量子计算机，以此作为你正在做一件根本不同事情的证明。
Could you maybe like dive in like why that matters? a lot of people in the field nowadays believe that simulating other quantum systems is perhaps going to be the first application of a quantum computer. Because these are sort of also the easier ones, so we can do those. There are interesting questions to ask about how quantum systems behave that we cannot ask because
你能深入讲讲为什么这很重要吗？该领域的许多人现在认为，模拟其他量子系统很可能是量子计算机的第一个应用。因为这些也相对更容易做到，所以我们可以做到这一点。关于量子系统如何表现，有一些有趣的问题是我们在过去无法提出的，因为
we cannot simulate quantum systems with many degrees of freedom that we could probably do with relatively low number of qubits. So maybe a few hundreds of qubits, you can already simulate quantum systems, molecules, like phases in condensed matter and things that are actually interesting. So at the beginning, I think they're going to be interesting for science, which, by the way, I think it's already a good application to start from. Let's build a machine that can help us. So first, quantum computers are exploring themselves, right?
我们无法用具有许多自由度的量子系统进行模拟，而用相对较少数量的量子比特，我们大概就能做到这一点。所以也许只要几百个量子比特，你就可以模拟量子系统、分子、凝聚态中的相以及现实中有趣的事情。因此在最初阶段，我认为它们对科学很有用，顺便说一句，我认为这已经是一个很好的切入点。让我们制造一台能够帮助我们的机器。所以首先，量子计算机正在探索它们自身，对吧？
Just can I build this thing? How can I build better? How can I scale it up? Then I think they're going to explore other quantum systems, answer some scientific questions that we have. Then I think those things are going to probably evolve into something that is already of some industrial value. Like I can simulate a molecule
我能造出这个东西吗？我该如何把它造得更好？我该如何扩展它的规模？然后我认为它们将去探索其他量子系统，解答我们所拥有的一些科学问题。接着我认为这些东西可能会演变成具有某种工业价值的东西。比如我可以模拟一个分子，
and I can maybe build better drugs or better nanomaterials or better materials for all kinds of usages in industry. And in parallel, there is then optimization problems that we hope to get some advantage from quantum computers. And I think those applications like breaking on encryption codes are a little bit more down the road. I think they just require a lot of qubits and a lot of error-corrected qubits. So some of those more, you know,
并且我或许可以制造出更好的药物、更好的纳米材料，或者适合工业中各种用途的更好材料。与此同时，还有一些优化问题，我们希望从量子计算机中获得某种优势。而我认为那些像破解加密代码这样的应用还有点遥远。我认为它们只是需要大量的量子比特和大量的纠错量子比特。所以其中一些更，你知道的，
near-term quantum simulation applications, I think also require less quantum error correction and maybe noisier qubits so i never that was thank you that's super eye-opening i guess i have fallen into this trap about like thinking of traveling salesman problem or np complete problems in general and like quantum computers going and attacking you know all those things that are really hard for computers to do today and maybe opening up new avenues but this thing you mentioned i guess not my field so i don't traditionally think about it as a computer field or my computer field which is which is eye-opening like how i guess if i elaborate a bit like drug modeling or interaction like how a molecule of a certain shape interacts
近期能实现的量子模拟应用，我认为对量子纠错的要求也更低，可能对充满噪声的量子比特也没那么苛刻。所以，我以前从来没有……谢谢你，这太开阔眼界了。我猜我曾陷入这样一个陷阱：认为旅行商问题或一般的NP完全问题，以及量子计算机去攻克所有那些今天对计算机来说很难的事情，并可能开辟新的途径。但你提到的这件事，我猜这不是我的领域，所以我过去通常不把它当作计算机领域或我所处的计算机领域来看待，这真的很开阔眼界。如果我再详细阐述一点，比如药物建模或相互作用——比如某种特定形状的分子如何在你的体内发挥作用，对于今天的计算机来说简直难如登天。事实上，看看无论哪个生物科技创业公司的失败率，显然，如果这很容易的话，他们早就做了。所以既然它并不容易，这一定相当困难。但你提到的是，在量子计算机发展的早期阶段，你可能就能开始在这些方面取得进展。这些事情甚至可以说是——我本来想说连计算机都无法解决，但更准确地说是今天计算机在实际中无法解决的问题。所以它们甚至不是，我不知道，我不知道它们是否被使用，但它们不是那种用来从根本上解决问题的工具。所以现在你说，也许量子计算机在材料和分子相互作用之类的事情上……这其实很鼓舞人心，因为每当听到你这样说，我总是会感到沮丧：“哦，当然啦，你可以解决一个10个比特的旅行商问题，所以，那就像是，你知道的，在我的计算机上花不了多长时间，虽然它很慢，但也没关系。”但你提到的是，嘿，
in your body is insanely hard on computers today. And in fact, like, I guess, looking at the whatever biotech startup failure rate, apparently, if it was easy, they would be doing it. And so that it's not, I mean, this must be pretty hard. But you're kind of mentioning that it may be earlier in the quantum computer thing that you can begin to make progress against those sorts of things which are are not really even i want to say solvable by computers but not practically solvable by computers today so they aren't even really i don't know i don't know if they're used or not but aren't aren't sort of like using to sort of fundamentally solve the problem and so now you're saying maybe quantum computers things
在当今的计算机上模拟你体内的东西是极其困难的。事实上，我觉得，看看不管什么生物科技初创公司的失败率，显然，如果这很容易的话，大家早就去做了。所以这绝非易事，我的意思是，这肯定相当难。但你刚才提到，在量子计算机发展的更早期阶段，你就可以开始针对这类问题取得进展，这些问题实际上甚至不是——我想说的是，不是计算机无法解决，而是当今计算机在实践中无法解决，所以它们甚至没有真正被——我不知道，我不知道它们是否被使用——但并没有真正被用来从根本上解决问题，所以现在你是在说，也许量子计算机...
like materials and molecular interaction this kind of thing that's actually that's encouraging because i always get sad this thing you say like, oh, sure, you can solve a 10-bit, you know, traveling salesman problem. So like, that's like, you know, it's not very long on my computer, even though it's slow, it doesn't matter. But you're mentioning, hey,
那在不同的领域其实仍然非常有用。是的，当然。这很可能是我们要探索的第一个方向。而这些都是你所了解的事情。所以今天，当你看看高性能计算机，比如超级计算机时，人们试图做的很多事情就是这样的。所以我认为这就是我们应该研究的方向。
that actually still could be very useful in a different domain. Yeah, for sure. This is probably the first direction to explore. And these are things that you know. So today, you look at high-performance computers like supercomputers, a lot of what people are trying to do are things like that. So I think that's where we should look into.
是的。顺便说一下，关于NP完全问题，顺我们提到NP完全问题时，我们并不认为量子计算机能带来指数级的加速。好吧，对于其中一些NP完全问题，我们知道量子计算机可以带来加速，但这是一种多项式（二次方）加速。哦。这其实归结于量子算法是如何工作的，以及其根本原因……
Yeah. So the thing with NP-complete problems, by the way, so with NP-complete problems, by the way, so with NP-complete problems, we don't think that quantum computers are going to give an exponential speedup. Okay, so for some of these NP-complete problems, we know that quantum computers could give a speedup, but it's a quadratic speedup. Oh. This actually goes down to how quantum algorithms work and so the fundamental...
如果量子计算机能够探索所有不同的可能性，就像人们有时描述的那样，并说：“好吧，嘿，这里是正确的路径，然后我们就能解决NP完全问题。”但事实并非如此，因为在量子算法的最后，
If a quantum computer could just explore all of the different possibilities, like sometimes people describe it and say, okay, hey, here is the right path then we can solve NP-complete problems. But that's not the case because at the end of the quantum algorithm,
你最终得到的其实也是所有结果的叠加态。而你并不想去测量，你不想——而且你只能测量一个，对吧？当我们测量时，我们只能测量一个状态。因此，要从量子系统中获得优势，你需要的不仅仅是同时探索所有不同的可能性。这就导致了一个事实：当你遇到一个完全没有结构的问题时——这正是这些NP完全问题的本质——从量子计算机中获得优势也就非常困难。所以我们知道我们可以获得二次方加速，这可能非常非常有用，如果我们有数百万个经过纠错的量子比特以及所有那些东西，那可能会非常了不起。你知道，在实践中为人工智能（AI）获得二次方
you actually also end up with a superposition of all the results. And you don't want to measure, you don't, and you can measure only one, right? When we measure, we only measure one state. So in order to get advantage from a quantum system, you need to do more than just explore all the different possibilities at once. And so that leads to the fact that when you have a problem that has completely no structure, which is the nature of these NP-complete problems, then it's also very hard to get an advantage from a quantum computer. So we know we can get a quadratic speedup, which could be very, very useful if we had millions of qubits that are error- and all that stuff that could be amazing you know practically getting a quadratic
加速，或者类似的事情，这本会是了不起的，但我们还没走到那一步。所以我认为我们在寻找那些你可以获得指数级加速的应用，至少在短期内是这样。而这些，其中一些有趣的事情，我认为与模拟量子系统、其他量子系统有关。我想我曾陷入过那个陷阱。我听说过，也知道那是错的，但我从来没听过其中的“为什么”，
speed up for you know ai right now or this would have been amazing so but but we're not there yet so i think we are looking for some of those things in which you can get an exponential speed up at least in the short term and these these and some of the interesting things, I think have to do with simulating quantum systems, other quantum systems. I think I had fallen into that trap. I had heard and I knew it was wrong, but I'd never heard like kind of why,
也就是：是的，你只需把它们放入叠加态，运行旅行商程序，它就会并行化整个算法，然后另一端就会蹦出最短路径。但我认为你指出的这一点，我猜我之前可能忽略了，但它感觉很有帮助：你可以并行运行所有这些事情。但随后在另一端，当你试图寻找答案时，
which is that, yeah, you just put in the superposition, you run the traveling salesman program and it in parallel, it parallelizes the entire algorithm and then out the other end, you know, pops the shortest path. But I think this thing you're pointing out, I guess I don't maybe I miss it, but it feels like it helps is like, you could you can run all of those things in parallel. But then at the other end, when you go to try to find out your
你最终又回到了最初的问题，那就是你必须不断地重新运行它，不断地观察它。你有点像是在这样做，但随后你又不得不通过某种方式把它“撤销”，因为它并不是你想要的格式。它不是那种正常的算法输出形式。完全正确。因此，你能够从并行运行所有这些事情这一事实中获得收益的唯一方法是，如果它们形成了我们所谓的干涉。这就回到了我刚才所说的话。这些振幅非常重要，也就是你所走的每一条路径都有这些权重，对吧？就像是什么，所以你可以把它想象成概率，
answer, you end up kind of back in the same problem, which is you have to keep rerunning it and keep like looking at it. And you sort of like, do it, but then you have to undo it by like, it's not in a form that you wanted. It is not in the sort of like normal algorithm output. Exactly. So the only way that you can actually get something from the fact that you're running all of those things in parallel is if they form what we call interference. And that's where I go back to what I said. It's very important that these amplitudes, so each path that you go has these weights, right? Like what's the, so you think about it as probability,
但它其实并不是概率。它是我们所说的概率振幅。它是概率的平方根。它是一个复数。所以它可以是负数，例如。然后当这些路径在这段并行计算中汇聚在一起时，它们会彼此发生干涉。以至于最终你得到的那个结果，是这种大规模干涉的结果。如果你能以某种方式构建算法，让所有通往错误计算结果的错误路径彼此抵消，
but it's not really a probability. It's what we call probability amplitude. It's this kind of like square root of probability. It's a complex number. So it can be negative, for example. And then when those come together along this parallel computation, they interfere with each other. So that at the end, the result that you get at the end is the result of this massive interference. And if you could build the algorithm in such a way that all the wrong paths leading to the wrong computational results cancel one another.
这就有点像海洋中的海浪。它们可以相互抚平，而通往正确计算结果的路径则相互增强。然后你就能获得加速。这实际上是我们发现量子力学的唯一途径，对吧？因为我们总是在最后进行测量。我们怎么知道量子系统本来就表现出量子特性呢？那是因为我们可以做，你可能
It's kind of like waves in the ocean. They can flatten one another while the path leading to the right computational results amplify one another. Then you get a speed up. This is actually the only way we could discover quantum mechanics, right? Because we always measure at the end. How do we know that quantum quantum systems behave quantum you know to begin with it's because we can do you know probably you've
听说过双缝干涉实验之类的东西，在那里你制造了这种干涉，这就是我们如何知道电子同时穿过了两个狭缝等等。所以，是的，对于这一点——我的意思是，这真是令人着迷，尽管我一无所知，只是作为一个业余爱好者，每当看到某个新闻发布会上的戏剧性事件时就会关注。比如我不会点名某某公司发布了拥有某某功能的量子计算机，然后你会看到，在像那些极客聚集的Hacker News上，或者斯科特·阿伦森（Scott Aaronson）的博客上说：“得了吧，那纯属胡扯，那家伙做的事，我们甚至无法证明，你完全可以用经典计算机来做，我们根本不知道。”这就像是，什么？你怎么会有
heard like the the double slit experiments and things like that where you create this interference and that's how we know that the electron went into two slits at the same time and so on and so so yeah yeah that on that one i mean that's a fascinating like not knowing anything but armchair following the kind of drama every time there's a press release from i won't name companies like x company has a quantum computer that did y thing and then you see you know on the the nerdy like hacker news or whatever scott aronson's blog says like yeah bs like that guy we actually can't prove that what they did, like you could have done it classically, like we don't know. And it's like, what, how do you have
这种存在主义危机：你宣称这是一台量子计算机，你把所有的激光器都降温浸入巨大的液氮中——虽然我甚至不知道那是不是液氮，这种巨大的、超级酷炫的设备，然后你运行了这个东西，最后你甚至不知道你所做的是不是你原本打算做的事情？这就像是，它有那种超级酷炫的设备，你运行了这个东西，然后你甚至不知道最后你做的是不是你试图去做的事情。这在我的脑海里总是一个滑稽的场景，就像，哦，天哪，我想我懂得还不够多，所以无法真正了解。但看着别人为之挣扎，其实有一种幸灾乐祸的感觉，我猜。是的。不，我认为澄清这一点非常重要。对这个领域来说，澄清以下几点非常重要：
this existential crisis that like, you have this thing you're claiming as a quantum computer, you lower all these lasers into a giant liquid nitrogen, but I don't even know it's liquid nitrogen, this giant, like, act of super cool, you know, stuff, and you run this thing, and then you don't know at the end, if what you did was even the thing you attempted to do. Like, it have that super cool, you know, stuff, and you run this thing, and then you don't know at the end if what you did was even the thing you attempted to do. Like, it's sort of this funny, like, in my head, I always, like, oh, man, I guess I don't know enough to know. But it's sort of a schadenfreude, I guess, to watch other people struggle with that. Yeah. No, and I think it's very important to clarify. It's very important for the field to clarify
有很多事情是量子计算机无法做到的，对吧？或者说，有些测试是我们无法证明的。这本身就很棒。你知道，我们正在试图制造一台以前没有人造过的机器，并且我们知道它在某些方面可以比经典计算机更快。这是我们目前制造过的最疯狂的机器，
that there are many things that quantum computers would not be able to do, okay? Or, you know, a test that we cannot prove. It's great by itself. You know, we're trying to build a machine that nobody built before and that we know can do certain things faster than classical computers, which is the craziest machine that we know can do certain things faster than classical computers,
我们知道它可以比经典计算机更快地完成某些事情，这是我们迄今为止制造的最疯狂的机器，对吧？为了经典计算机的发展，人们投入了数万亿美元。我认为我们制造这台机器、测试它、
which is the craziest machine that we've built so far, right? There's like trillions of dollars that went into the development of classical computers. I think it makes sense that we will build this machine and we will test it
看看它能做什么、不能做什么，这是合情合理的。而且我们知道某些算法，比如秀尔算法（Shor's algorithm），确实能做到一些事情。那么，为什么我们需要超越这些的东西呢？为什么我们需要制造没有足够事实依据的炒作呢？你知道，我认为我们有充分的理由获得资金来制造这些机器，对吧？是的。是的。我不敢说自己懂营销的权衡取舍，但作为一个工程师，我懂你的意思。我也经常这么说：为什么我们不能实话实说它能做什么呢？它已经够惊艳了。所以我们刚才讨论了
and we will see what it can do and what it cannot do. And we know certain algorithms like Shor algorithm that can do stuff. But so why do we need more than that? Like, why do we need to generate hype that is based on grounded enough? You know, I think that we have all the right reasons to get funding to build these machines, right? Yeah. Yeah. I won't claim to know the trade-offs of marketing, but I hear you as like an engineer. I say the same thing. Like, why can't we just say truthfully the thing it does like it's pretty amazing so we we kind of talked about like a
很多非常非常底层的技术，以及一些更宏大的问题。然后我知道我们接下来要谈论的是算法设计，对吧？所以人们在思考，正如你所提到的，这些东西是振幅，试图设计它们来实现相消干涉——那么，有没有人正从事，我不知道，类似于当今计算机科学的工作，比如从事这些算法的研究或编写这些程序的代码？还是说，现在还为时尚早？有人在那个高层级上工作吗？那会是什么样子？今天编程量子计算机究竟意味着什么？是的，有人在做这方面的工作，但还不够多，我想这么说。而且我认为这实际上是我希望改变的一点。
lot of really really really low level stuff and and some of these bigger questions and then i know we're talking about like algorithmic design right so people thinking as you mentioned like these things are amplitudes trying to design them to cancel out like are there people who have i don't know like the equivalent of computer science jobs today, like working in these algorithms or programming these things? Or is it, it's still too early? Like, are people working at that high level? And what does that kind of look like? What does it mean to kind of like program quantum computers today? Yeah, so there are people working on it, but not enough, I would say. And I think that's actually one thing that I hope would change.
但原因很明显。首先，要提出一种在根本水平上比经典计算机更快地解决某个问题的量子算法是非常困难的。就像是以指数级甚至二次方级的速度比经典计算机更快地解决问题。这是一个非常困难的问题。很多非常聪明的人都尝试过。我们有一些例子，但都是非常重要的例子。我的意思是，如果你明天破解了RSA加密，那将是轰动性的，但要找到新的算法非常困难。我认为没有足够的人去尝试的另一个原因是我们还没有
But the reasons are clear. First of all, it's very hard to come up with a quantum algorithm that actually solves something faster than a classical computer on a fundamental level. Like solves it exponentially or even quadratically faster than a classical computer. That's a very hard problem. And many very smart people tried. And we have, you know, some examples, but very important examples. I mean, if you break the RSA tomorrow, it's huge, but it's very hard to find new ones. The other reason why I think that not enough people are trying is because we don't have
这些机器。所以，你知道，这是两码事。就像想想经典计算机。想想看，经典计算机现在存在了多少年，存在了多少个世纪，人们依然在不断提出不仅在编程方面、而且在算法方面的新范式，对吧？
the machines. So, you know, it's a different thing. Like, think about classical computers. Like, think about, like, do you think, you know, classical computers now are what, like, I don't know, so many years, so many decades exist, and still people come up with new paradigms in not just programming, but algorithms, you know?
所以仍然有新型的算法。有新型的启发式算法。人们会想出各种各样的东西，但他们有一个巨大的优势：他们可以直接在计算机上进行尝试，看看它是否管用，对吧？这是一个巨大的改变。这就是为什么我认为，要真正让足够多的人
So there are still new types of algorithms. There are new types of heuristics. There is all kinds of stuff that people come up with, but they have a big advantage. They could just try it out on the computer and see if it works, right? And it's a game changer. So that's why I think that to really have enough people
去尝试编写新的算法，我们确实需要更多的量子计算机，而建造这些机器本身就是另一个挑战。谈到差分机和阿达（Ada），你知道，她们弄懂了这些分析机的编程并试图将其付诸实践。你可以谈谈ENIAC计算机，你知道的，或者早期计算机，破解谜团（Enigma）或ENIAC，诸如此类的事情。在这样一个谱系中：一方面我们有理论上的东西，人们在对这些算法进行思考——我不想说是从数学角度，而是从抽象的角度。所以我们提到了秀尔算法或类似的东西，这些是人们甚至在硬件出现去尝试它们之前就已经构想出来的，一直到编程语言被发明出来。然后，正如你所提到的，我们不断迭代这些想法、框架、编程语言和范式——比如函数式编程与面向对象编程——我们无论如何都还没搞清楚今天我们在做什么，但确实出现了一场方法论的爆发。在那种相同的——我不知道这是否能对应上，但在那种
trying to program new algorithms, I think that we do need more quantum computers, which is another challenge to build those things. talking about the differential engine and Ada, you know, kind of figuring out programming of these analytical engines and trying to kind of work through that. You can talk about the ENIAC computer, you know, or the early computers, you know, cracking the Enigma or ENIAC, these kind of things, like on the spectrum of like, hey, we have a theoretical thing and people are thinking, I don't want to say mathematically, but abstractly about these algorithms. So we mentioned things like Shor's algorithm or these things that people had even before maybe the hardware was there to even try them, you know, up to programming languages are invented. And then, as you mentioned, we keep iterating the ideas, frameworks and programming languages and paradigms and you know functional versus object oriented like we still haven't figured out what we're doing today by any means but there's been this sort of explosion of approaches on that same i don't know that it maps but in that same
语境下，你会说今天的量子计算机处于什么位置？有些算法你可以在它们上面运行，但可能正如你所说的那样，它们并非普遍可及。你觉得我们在这种谱系中处于什么位置？并不是处于最最开始的阶段。那是20世纪90年代的事了。当时人们必须完全脱离硬件来思考这些量子算法。而现在已经有了量子计算机，人们可以访问它们并进行编程，
kind of like context where would you say like quantum computers lay today like there are some you could run some algorithms on them but like maybe they're like you said not universally accessible where do you feel like we are on that kind of spectrum? Not at the very, very beginning. So that was during the 90s. People had to think about these quantum algorithms completely detached from hardware. So now there are quantum computers and people can access them and program,
但它仍然是小规模的。所以我觉得，如果他们得不到足够的……而且你知道，这里有很多噪声，所以你得不到正确的答案。我认为我们还处于非常早期的阶段，但我认为，是的，这就是为什么我们开始拥有这些量子云计算服务是一件好事，人们可以登录并进行尝试。并不是说明天你就会拥有1000万程序员
but it's still very small scale. So I think that it's still hard to do that if they don't get enough, you know, and, you know, there's a lot of noise, so you don't get the right answer. And I think we're very early, but I think, yes, I think that's why it's great that we start having those, you know, quantum cloud computing services that people can log in and can try. It's not that tomorrow, you know, you're going to have like 10 million programmers,
去尝试开发新的算法，但我认为这会增加尝试的人数，并且有助于向人们普及这方面的知识。然后你就会开始有越来越多的人进入这个领域。但我认为这仍然是非常早期的阶段，是的。我以前见过那些东西，你知道，登录并提交你的任务。它真的是在
you know, trying to develop new algorithms, but I think it will increase the number of people who are trying and it helps, you know, educating people about this. So then you kind of start having more and more people going into this field. But I think this is very early stage, yeah. So I have seen those before, you know, log on and submit your job. Does it actually run on a
量子计算机上运行的吗？还是说它是一个虚拟机？就像你在慢速模拟量子计算机上运行，但结果应该是一样的？不，你今天可以在真正的量子计算机上运行。你可以使用AWS Braket来做到这一点。那是他们的量子计算服务。IBM Quantum。Azure也有量子服务。所以在所有这些服务中，你既可以在模拟器上运行，也可以在真正的机器上运行。所以你也可以在真正的机器上运行。然后你可以比较在真实机器上和在模拟器上得到的结果，你可以看到噪声水平。是的，这很棒。看看模拟器有多好。
quantum computer or is it like a VM? Like you're running on the simulation of the quantum computer slower, but the results should be the same? No, you can run today on a real quantum computer. So you can do that using AWS Bracket. That's their quantum computing service. IBM Quantum. Azure has quantum service. So in all of them, you can run either on a simulator or on a real machine. So you could run on a real machine as well. And then you can compare what you get with a real machine and a simulator and you can see the noise level. And yeah, it's great. See how good the simulator is.
所以我们构建了这个“三明治”结构，你知道的，一堆底层的东西，一点高层算法的东西。然后如果我回想你在开头关于你们所处位置的说法，感觉它似乎正好落在中间。那种不属于弄清量子比特下一个最佳物质的实用性层面——虽然你可以告诉我我是否错了——也不属于应用层面的东西，你知道的，去编写那些算法，而是处于中间位置。我的理解对吗？那项工作最终看起来是什么样的？是的，所以当你想到——当你想到计算机时，这里有一个技术栈，技术栈中有很多层，而且在你接触到能够编程和编写算法的东西之前，还需要几个抽象层。
So I think we set up this sandwich like, you know, a bunch of low level stuff, a little bit of the high level algorithm stuff. And then if I sort of listen to what you were saying in the beginning about where you guys kind of set up, it sort of feels like it lies in the middle there. Like the practicalness of like not figuring out the next best substance for a qubit didn't sound like although maybe you can tell me i'm wrong and maybe not the like you know application layer stuff you know actually you know sort of writing those algorithms but but kind of laying in the middle do i kind of have the the picture right and like what does that work end up looking like yeah so when you think about so so when you think about a computer, there's a stack, and there are so many layers in the stack, and there are also several abstraction layers that are required until you reach something that you can program and write algorithms with.
因此，对于量子机器，我们处于这些中间层，即控制层，包括控制硬件和控制软件。控制硬件基本上是在程序运行期间协调算法的东西。这就是实时运行量子算法的东西，对吧？因为它对发送到QPU的脉冲进行定序。所以你可以把QPU
And so quantum machines, we are in those middle layers, the control layers, both control hardware and control software. So the control hardware is the thing that's basically orchestrates during the runtime of the program, it orchestrates the algorithm. So that's the thing that actually runs the quantum algorithm in real time, right? Because it sequences the pulses that you send to the QPU. So you can kind of think about the qpu think about it as the alu in your cpu but you need to send it all the commands you need to do it in the right sequence and you need to and in fact with quantum because of the noise you need to do it with the right timing as well which is something that you don't think about in classical because there is no noise
想象成你CPU中的ALU（算术逻辑单元），但你需要向它发送所有的命令，你需要按正确的顺序执行它们，而且实际上对于量子计算来说，由于噪声的存在，你还需要以正确的时序来执行它们，这是你在经典计算中不需要考虑的，因为没有噪声。
if you push me more into this direction we can talk about the existence of time, but I don't know if you have time for that. That's awesome. So I just looked this up. I went on AWS Bracket and it sounds like basically you could do things that led to the disaster in the Half-Life video game for 68 cents.
如果你把我往这个方向进一步推进，我们可以讨论时间的存在性，但我不知道你是否有时间谈这个。太棒了。我刚刚查了一下。我上了AWS Braket，听起来基本上你可以花68美分做出导致《半条命》电子游戏中那场灾难的事情。
That's basically what I'm getting. So you can go to AWS Bracket. It costs 30 cents to get the task up and running. And then it costs 0.0002 per shot. And in their example, that's in dollars. Their example is example two here. A researcher runs a quantum annealing program, which is I'm pretty sure what created the headcrabs in Half-Life 1, on a D-Wave Advantage quantum computer in Oregon, and it cost them 68 cents. So it's just absolutely amazing that you can just do this.
我基本上就是这个意思。所以你可以去AWS Braket。启动任务需要30分钟，哦不，是30美分。然后每次运行收费0.0002美元。在他们的例子中，那是按美元计算的。他们的例子是这里的第二个例子。一名研究人员在俄勒冈州的一台D-Wave Advantage量子计算机上运行了一个量子退火程序——我相当确定这就是《半条命1》中那些头蟹的创造原因——这花费了他68美分。所以你只需花这个钱就能做到这一点，这简直太神奇了。
So folks at home, you know, get a quantum program and spend 68 cents doing this. If nothing else, you could tell your friends. It's pretty amazing. Yeah, yeah, it is. It is, I think, very cool and pretty amazing indeed. So yeah, so going back to that control area, so it really is the part that runs the entire quantum algorithm and sequences it. And on top of that, and so it has to have also a programming interface, which is kind of like when you think about it, the assembly level language of the quantum computer, right? And that's what we do.
所以家里的听众们，你知道的，去搞个量子程序，花68美分做这个吧。不管怎样，你都可以跟你的朋友吹嘘一番。这真的很神奇。对，对，确实如此。我认为这非常酷，而且确实非常惊人。所以，是的，回到那个控制区域，它确实是运行整个量子算法并对其进行定序的部分。除此之外，它还必须具备一个编程接口，你可以把它想象成量子计算机的汇编级语言，对吧？而这正是我们所做的。
So we make the control system, which is classical hardware in which we have actually designed a new type of processor, another quantum processor, a classical processor, that gets these instructions from us, these low-level quantum processor, a classical processor, that gets these instructions from us, these low-level quantum instructions, and then it runs the entire program on the QPU, on the quantum processor, against the quantum processor, right? So it's, yeah.
所以我们制造了控制系统，这是经典硬件，我们在其中实际上设计了一种新型处理器，另一个量子处理器——一个经典处理器，它从我们这里接收这些指令、这些底层量子指令，然后它在QPU（量子处理器）上运行整个程序，针对量子处理器运行，对吧？所以，是的。
And then on top of that, then you have all the control software stuff, because, you know, this assembly-level language that I mentioned, it's talking the language of pulses. Send this pulse to this qubit, send that pulse, change the frequency of this pulse, change the amplitude of that pulse, but we want to get to the gates, right? We want to get to program gates and algorithms
除此之外，你还有所有的控制软件，因为我提到过这种汇编级语言，它用的是脉冲的语言。发送这个脉冲到这个量子比特，发送那个脉冲，改变这个脉冲的频率，改变那个脉冲的幅度，但我们想要到达门电路层面，对吧？我们想要编写门电路和算法
so you need to have another layer which is called the control software layer in which you run a bunch of complicated calibrations it's a graph of complicated calibrations that run programs on the control hardware and the quantum processor in order to calibrate what are the parameters of the system or how do I perform gate and so on and once you calibrated those gates then you can create a compiler
所以你需要有另一层，叫做控制软件层，在这一层中你要运行一堆复杂的校准，它是一个复杂校准的图，在控制硬件和量子处理器上运行程序，以便校准系统的参数是什么，或者我如何执行门电路等等。一旦你校准了这些门电路，你就可以创建一个编译器
that compiles from the gate level languages down to the pass level and down to the machine. So if I hazard a guess that the timing and such is pretty complicated, so QPU probably, are you guys using like FPGAs or are you like doing ASIC tapeouts?
它能将从门级语言编译到脉冲级，并最终编译到机器。如果我猜的话，时序之类的东西相当复杂，所以QPU可能，你们是用FPGA还是在做ASIC流片？
Or if you can't share, that's fine. You can hand wave and say black box. That's acceptable as well. I imagine you mentioned microwaves before. These things, the timescales need to be very well timed, very precise. Is that roughly the kind of stuff you guys are talking about as opposed to DSPs? So right now we're using FPGAs to implement what they call the pulse processor. So again, that component that receives the instructions and runs them. And so currently
或者如果不能透露也没关系。你可以挥挥手说是个黑盒。这也是可以接受的。我想你之前提到过微波。这些东西，时间尺度需要非常准确、非常精确。大致就是你们在谈论的这类东西，而不是DSP？所以目前我们正在使用FPGA来实现他们所谓的脉冲处理器。所以同样地，那个接收指令并运行它们的组件。因此目前
we're implementing it with FPGAs, the biggest FPGAs in the market. And it's a bunch of FPGAs if you want to control a relatively large QPU with tens of qubits, you would need many FPGAs. So at some point, yeah, I mean, the field will go to a dedicated ASIC to do the quantum control. Currently, it's still in the relatively early stages where you want to get the flexibility and you want to change stuff as you go. And so you do that with FPGAs.
我们正在用FPGA来实现它，市场上最大的FPGA。如果你想控制一个拥有几十个量子比特的相对较大的QPU，你需要许多FPGA。所以在某个时候，是的，这个领域将会转向专用的ASIC来进行量子控制。目前，它仍然处于相对早期阶段，你希望获得灵活性，并且希望在进行过程中随时做出改变。所以你用FPGA来做这件事。
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, yeah. That's, I mean, it sounds fascinating. So Quantum Machines as a company, are you guys, so it sounds like you have some of this stuff. Is it something people can try out today? Like, could I just like go to your website
是的，完全正确。是的，完全正确。对，对。这，我的意思是，听起来太迷人了。那么作为一家公司的Quantum Machines，你们，听起来你们有其中的一些东西。这是人们今天就可以尝试的东西吗？比如，我可以直接去你们的网站
and like learn how to use your stuff? Or is it more like, no, no, no, you got to get in the field and it would serve some of these other things we're talking about? Yeah, no, definitely. So at Quantum Mach in the field and it would serve some of these other things we're talking about? Yeah, no, definitely. So at Quantum Machines, we have our first system. It's been in the market for three years now.
然后学习如何使用你们的东西吗？还是更像是，不，不，不，你必须深入这个领域，它将服务于我们正在讨论的其他一些事情？是的，没错。所以在Quantum Machines，我们有了我们的第一套系统。它已经在市场上销售三年了。
Our uniqueness, by the way, our uniqueness is that our pulse processor actually is not just running quantum operations. It's running also classical operations, and it's running. So it brings, it integrates classical processing into the heart of the quantum control layer. It allows you to program in a single code, which is our programming language, QUA, allows you to program the classical operations and the quantum operations, which are the pulses and measurements, in order to integrate between them. So for example, when you try to do quantum error correction, you need to measure stuff, you need to measure your qubits during the runtime, and you need to process them classically and respond to that again with the next gates or pulses. So to do that...
顺便说一下，我们的独特性在于，我们的脉冲处理器不仅在运行量子操作。它还在运行经典操作。因此，它将经典处理整合到量子控制层的核心。它允许你用单一的代码进行编程，也就是我们的编程语言QUA，允许你对经典操作和量子操作（即脉冲和测量）进行编程，以便将它们集成在一起。例如，当你试图进行量子纠错时，你需要测量一些东西，你需要在运行期间测量你的量子比特，你需要对它们进行经典处理，并通过下一个门电路或脉冲再次做出响应。所以要做到这一点...
Oh, it's like path dependent. Yeah, I see. Yes, you need to have feedback. So you need to have very fast real-time feedback between sending quantum instructions, which are the pulses, measuring your qubits, which is measuring signals coming back from the QPU, processing them, doing classical processing on them, which again, you want the programmer to do from the programming environment. And then the algorithm needs to understand in real time that it has to respond with the right pulse
哦，这就像是路径相关的。是的，我明白了。是的，你需要有反馈。因此，在发送量子指令（即脉冲）、测量量子比特（即测量来自QPU的返回信号）、处理它们、对它们进行经典处理（程序员同样希望在编程环境中完成这些）之间，你需要非常快速的实时反馈。然后算法需要实时理解它必须用正确的脉冲做出响应
to correct an error, for example. So when you say like controls, you mean like even control loops. So you're like controlling the computer, but then also control, like it's controls all the way down. Okay, I think I see what you're meaning now. Yeah, we're running the entire sequence.
例如，来纠正一个错误。所以当你谈到控制时，你的意思是甚至包括控制循环。所以你不仅在控制计算机，还在进行控制，就像全都是控制一样。好吧，我想我明白你的意思了。是的，我们正在运行整个序列。
So for example, if I want to loop over a gate, I want to send gate 500 times, I write a for loop to run this gate 500 times. But what if I want to measure a qubit, and based on the measurement, I want to branch. So I want to say, so this is called mid-circuit measurements that affect the quantum circuit itself. So we are the first to introduce such features into a commercial control system that allows, for example, mid-circuit measurements and branching of the algorithm.
因此，例如，如果我想对一个门电路进行循环，我想把一个门电路发送500次，我写一个for循环来运行这个门电路500次。但是如果我想测量一个量子比特，并且根据测量结果，我想进行分支。所以我想说，这被称为影响量子电路本身的电路中测量。因此，我们是第一个将这种功能引入商业控制系统的人，它允许例如电路中测量和算法的分支。
So if statement, like when you think about it, an if statement is such a, it's the basic thing right like if x equals zero do that if not do something else that did not exist and still doesn't exist in most quantum computers today that you cannot measure qubits and based on the results decide what you're doing next that has to be done in the classical control system right because that's the thing that measures and branches the the sequence decide the next pulses yeah right so that's what we do. That's the key stuff that we do. And we've been selling. We have over 200 customers around the world.
所以if语句，当你仔细想想，if语句是如此基本的东西，比如如果x等于零就执行那个，否则就做点别的，这在当今大多数量子计算机中是不存在的，而且仍然不存在，你不能测量量子比特并根据结果决定下一步做什么，这必须在经典控制系统中完成，对吧？因为那是测量和分支序列、决定下一个脉冲的东西，对吧？所以这就是我们所做的。这是我们做的关键事情。而且我们一直在销售。我们在世界各地拥有200多位客户。
So we are over 130 people in the company. So yeah, it's great to be in a company that's really in the action of everything that's happening today. So we're not sitting developing something that's going to be used in 10 years. We're really working with our customers very intensively. Are you looking for interns, full-time people? How has Quantum Machines as a company to refer?
所以我们公司有130多名员工。所以，能够身处一家真正处于当今发生的一切之核心的公司，这太棒了。所以我们不是坐在那里开发将在10年后使用的东西。我们真的在和客户进行非常深入的合作。你们在寻找实习生、全职员工吗？作为一家公司的Quantum Machines怎么样？
I mean, this technology, I could go on way, way longer. I have a lot more questions, but I tried to be considerate here. But are you guys enjoying the place to work? People are liking it. You're hiring. What is it kind of like as a company culture? So Quantum Machines, I think it's a fun place to come work at. We have people all around the world, actually.
我的意思是，这项技术，我可以聊得更久得多。我还有更多问题，但我在这里尽量考虑周全。但是你们喜欢这个工作地方吗？人们喜欢它吗？你们在招聘吗？作为一家公司的企业文化是怎样的？Quantum Machines，我认为这是一个工作起来很有趣的地方。实际上，我们在世界各地都有员工。
We have people in the U.S Actually, we have people in the US, in Europe, and in Israel. So we're based in Israel, but we have people in US, Europe, Canada. We are looking for both interns as well as full-time employees. We're looking for great
我们在美国有员工。实际上，我们在美国、欧洲和以色列都有员工。所以我们的总部在以色列，但我们在美国、欧洲、加拿大都有员工。我们正在寻找实习生以及全职员工。我们在寻找优秀的人才
software engineers. I know that this podcast is being listened by top-notch software people. So I know that this podcast is being listened by, you know, top notch software people. So I think that's, that's yeah. I mean, and I'm excited to talk here because I mean,
软件工程师。我知道这个播客有很多顶级的软件人才在听。所以我知道这个播客有很多，你知道的，顶级软件人才在听。所以我觉得，是的。我的意思是，我很兴奋能在这里说话，因为我的意思是，
I think that we really need great people, software, also hardware people that are not necessarily coming from quantum, but actually bringing, you know, their expertise into the field. It's very important that we don't let the crazy physicists try to build a quantum computer because that's not going to work
我认为我们真的需要优秀的人才，软件人才，还有那些不一定来自量子领域，但实际上把他们的专业知识带到这个领域的硬件人才。非常重要的一点是，我们不能让疯狂的物理学家试图去制造量子计算机，因为如果没有真正的工程师来帮忙的话，那是行不通的
without the the real engineers coming coming uh and helping out so so we're really looking for um great people to that that want to learn about this there's a lot of stuff to do in many layers in the stack. Yeah, I worked briefly for some people doing laser physics. And yeah, I can relate to you. I appreciate what they do. I can't do it. But yeah, that sounds fascinating.
所以我们真的在寻找那些想要了解这方面的伟大人才，在技术栈的许多层面上都有很多事情要做。是的，我曾为做激光物理学的人短暂工作过。是的，我能理解你。我很赞赏他们所做的事情。我做不到。但是，是的，听起来太迷人了。
Well, thank you so much for your time. I appreciate you coming on. This has been helpful for me. I learned a ton. I'm excited again. I want to go do a ton of Google searches, which I try not to do during the podcast. You hear the clacking on the keyboard. Jason's doing that for us. But you really stimulated me. So I know people out there are going to love it. Great topic. I feel like it's like, right. Like it's happening. I feel like it's one of those things, you know, it's not like an overnight thing, but like you can kind of see, see the changes, you know, setting up and we'll see, you know, we'll see what happens in the next few years, but like, it definitely feels like a really exciting field. Yeah. Thank you so much. I mean, this, this, this was a very fun to, to come and speak to you guys Jason, Patrick, I mean appreciate that, you guys are awesome and yeah hope to be here maybe a few years
非常感谢你抽出时间。我很感激你能来。这对我有很大帮助。我学到了很多。我很兴奋，我又想去进行大量的Google搜索，我尽量在播客期间不这么做。你听到了键盘的敲击声。杰森正在为我们做这件事。但你真的启发了我。所以我知道外面的听众一定会喜欢它。很好的主题。我觉得就像是，对吧。就像它正在发生。我觉得这是那种事情，你知道的，它不是那种一夜之间发生的事情，但你可以某种程度上看到，看到变化正在发生，我们将拭目以待，你知道的，我们将看看未来几年会发生什么，但它绝对感觉是一个非常令人兴奋的领域。非常感谢。我的意思是，这，这，和你们俩交谈非常有趣，杰森、帕特里克，我的意思是谢谢你们，你们太棒了，是的，希望几年后能再来这里
from now when quantum computers are up and running solving simulated quantum systems and other stuff I thought you'd just break crypto and then you'll just be rich thank you so much for your time. And thank you everyone for listening in.
从现在开始，当量子计算机建立并运行，解决模拟量子系统和其他事情的时候。我以为你只是会破解密码然后你就发财了，非常感谢你抽出时间。也谢谢大家的收听。
And as always, thanks to our listeners. We appreciate it. And I'll see you next time. Music by Eric Barneller. music by eric barnmeller programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一如既往，感谢我们的听众。我们非常感激。我们下次再见。音乐由Eric Barneller创作。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，改编作品，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。